[موسيقى]
يحكى في الاثر ان رجلا قدم الى الخليفه
المعتصم ينبئه انه كان في عموريه الواقعه
تحت الحكم البيزنطي وتقع على الطريق
العسكري من اسطنبول التركي الى قلقيليه
الفلسطينيه وانه شاهد هناك امراه مسلمه
جليله في السوق يسحلها العسكر الى السجن
فصاحت في لهفه وحرقه وغضب ومعتصماه
ومعتصماه مستغيثه بالخليفه المعتصم الذي
ماء وصل اليه النداء حتى ارسل رساله الى
حاكم عموريه وفيها من امير المؤمنين الى
كلب الروم حرر المراه المسلمه من السجن
والا اتيتك بجيش بدايته عندك ونهايته عندي
لم يستجب الحاكم الرومي فانطلق المعتصم
بجيشه حتى اخضعه واستسلم مع جيشه فدخل
المعتصم عمريه بنفسه باحثا عن المراه
المستغيثه حتى وجدها فسالها هل اجابك
المعتصم يا اختاه قالت نعم اجابني اعز
الله ملكك يا امير المؤمنين بحسب من المجد
انك ثارت لي الى العناوين
مساجد اثيوبيا تهدم فوق رؤوس المصلين
وعلماء المسلمين يحذرون
الجزيره ترصد الحرب الطائفيه على مسلمي
الهند من المسافه صفر البيت الابيض يعاقب
اوغندا السمراء بعد تجريمها الشذوذ الجنسي
ثمانون سنه من اغتصاب الاطفال في كنائس
اسبانيا يفتح ملفاتها مؤتمر كاثوليكي
الباتشينو باعوامه الثلاثه والثمانين
ينتظر مولودا من صديقته العشرينية
[موسيقى]
جئناك لاجئين من هول ما عنيناه من الظلم
والعذاب
قال لنا محمد
اذهبوا الى الحبشه فان بها ملكا لا يظلم
عنده احد يا عمرو والله ما اسلم لكم هؤلاء
بجبل من ذهب انطلق يا جعفر ومن معك
وعيشه في ارضي بسلام مرحبا الحبسه التي
صار اسمها اثيوبيا كان فيها ملك لا يظلم
عنده احد لجا اليه المسلمون الاوائل بامر
النبويه شريف يوم ظلامهم بنو جلدتهم في
قريش وسعوا في قتلهم وتشريدهم اما اليوم
فاثيوبيا الحبشه براي مراقبين لم تعد امده
لمواطنيها المسلمين الذين يشكلون واحدا من
كل ثلاثه اثيوبيين مساجد في اثيوبيا تهدم
فوق رؤوس المصلين المعتصمين رفضا لهدمها
وعلى اجسادهم فقط قتل وجرح عدد من الشبان
المسلمين
الذين واجهوا جرافات هدم مساجدهم ففرقتهم
الشرطه بعنف شديد مستخدمه الرصاصه القاتل
وقد حذر الامين العام للاتحاد العالمي
لعلماء المسلمين الشيخ علي القرداغي مما
وصفه بالتصعيد الخطير ضد بيوت الله في
اثيوبيا والتمادي بقهر وقتل واضطهاد
المسلمين والمسلمات حجه حكومه اديس ابابا
متطابقه تماما مع دفتر الحجج الاسرائيليه
لهدم ممتلكات الفلسطينيين فالمساجد
المستهدفه في اقليم اوروميا الاثيوبي
مبنيه بطريقه مخالفه للقانون تقول الحكومه
وهدمها ضروري لمشاريع التطوير العمراني
لمشروع شيجر سيتي الجديد الذي مرت جرافاته
فوق انقاذ 23 مسجدا حتى نهايه هذا الاسبوع
املنا بالله ثم برؤساء الدول الاسلاميه
تقول امراه اثيوبيه مسلمه مستصرخه ضمائر
الحكام على طريقه سيده عموريه
فيرجى مما يعرف شيئا عن هذه الفتاه
الاثيوبيه تزويدها بعناوين اضرحه المستعصم
وابن الوليد والقعقاع وابن العاص وسعد بن
ابي وقاص والمغيره وابن الجراح والسلطان
صلاح الدين
لا تخلونا عملنا فيلا ثم فيكم اخواننا
المسلمين اكثر من الثمانيه حاليا صاروا
شهيدين والحمد لله بس اهالينا برضو
محبوسين في المسجد اخواننا وحالينا مو
قادرين نطلعوا عمرهم كبار محبوسين جوه في
المسجد الانوار يا امه محمد انو الاسلام
مو الونا كلنا يرقص على المسلمين يا رؤساء
المسلمين عملنا بربنا ثم فيكم برنامج
المسافه صفر على قناه الجزيره يسال من
اشعل الفتيل فتيل الحرب الطائفيه الممنهجه
ضد مسلمي الهند اما من يطفئ الفتيل فتيل
ناري مشاريع الاباده فهذا سؤال لا تجيب
عليه حلقه تلفزيونيه بل امه عظمى تعاني
اليوم من شح في البصر والسمع والنطق
السليم كشف التحقيق بالوثائق والشهادات عن
وجود تنظيمات متطرفه سعت على مدار سنوات
لاستهداف المسلمين استكشف نتائج التحقيق
الفيدرالي بشكل واضح عن وجود معسكرات
تدريب سريه ومنشات لصنع القنابل تتبع
لسيطره المنظمه
باتت مقاطع الفيديو التي توافق اعتداء
المتطرفين الهندوس على المسلمين ومساجدهم
وممتلكاتهم حدثا يوميا في الهند يرى
مراقبون ان السلطات الهنديه لا تظهر جديه
في ربعه ولا يحظى باهتمام من قبل العالم
الاسلامي
تمكن فريق المسافه صفر ايضا من الوصول الى
ولايه اسام اقصى شمال شرقي البلاد والى
مدى براديش في الجنوب الغربي حيث يعيش
المسلمون في كلا الولايتين اضطهادا واسعا
وهجمات متصاعده من قبل المتطرفين الهندوس
اضيف اليها اجراءات حكوميه عقابيه كل هذا
الاستنفار للعصبيات الطائفيه يخفي خلفه
فسادا حكوميا هنديا كبيرا وتخلفا عن خدمه
المواطنين فيشغلون بالفتن على الهويه
تماما كما يحدث دائما في لبنان ففي الخبر
التالي تنظم عائلات هنديه سلسله بشريه
احتجاجا على تلوث نهر اليامون الذي يقصده
الهندوس ويرمون في مياهه نذورهم من
الدراهم
ليلتقطها اطفال الاسر الفقيره المعدمه
غوصا في السموم لشراء الخبز والبقاء على
قيد الحياه في كل صباح يتنقل ساني كومار
البالغ من العمر 16 عاما وصديقه الصغير
بول سينغ في الوحل السام لنهر يامونا
بمجرد ان يرى ساني احدا يقدم قربانه من
العملات يغوص في النهر لالتقاطها
عندما يفتح عينيه تحت الماء يتعرض للمواد
الكيميائيه مباشره وقد يتسبب استنشاق
الابخره في حدوث تلف خطير في الرئه لكن
الصبيان يقضيان ساعه كامله في الماء قبل
ان يخرجها ومعهما القليل من العملات لا
تتعدى قيمتها يورو واحدا نهر يا منى هو
امي انه يطعمني انا وعائلتي اذا لم نغص في
النهر ننام جياعا ولا يكون لدينا طعام ولا
مال شاهدوا الان كيف سينهار في ولايه بهار
الهنديه جسر قيد الانشاء الخاطئ في ظل
فساد التلزمات والمقاولات الحكوميه
الحكومه الهنديه تتمكن دائما من ضبط اي
مواطن متهم بحيزه كيلو ونص او اثنين من
لحم البقر لكنها لم تتمكن من حمايه ركاب
القطارات من اعنف حادث ثلاثي قتل ما يقارب
ثلاث مئه مواطن وجرح مئات اخرين رئيس
الحكومه نارين درامودي اكتفى بتعزيه ذوي
الضحايا عبر تويتر فيما حدد وزير السكه
الحديد اشويني فيشناو سبب الحادث والاشخاص
المسؤولين عنه لكن لا تؤاخذوه فهو لا
يستطيع الان كشف التفاصيل الحديث المروع
وقع عند السابعه مساء بالتوقيت المحلي في
ولايه اوديشا الشرقيه الهند عندما تصادم
قطاران ممتلئان بالركاب مع ثالث محمل
بالبضائع الناجون يشهدون على هول الصدمه
وعندما خرجت اخيرا من القطار رايت شخصا
فقد يده واخر فقد ساقه واخر تشوه تماما
رئيس الو زراء الهندي قدم التعازي لاسر
الضحايا على تويتر تقول شركه سكك الحديديه
الهنديه ان شبكتها تنقل اكثر من 13 مليون
شخص يوميا الا نسيجي السلام في قطاراتها
متقلب بسبب تقادم البنيه التحتيه
[موسيقى]
الزعيم الكوري الشمالي كيم جونغ اون لا
يياس والصاروخ الذي يفشل اليوم سينجح غيره
غدا لكن الولايات المتحده قلقه حيال
الزعيم الاحمر فقد يرمي هيروشيما ونكازاكي
بالنبوي قد يحتل العراق وافغانستان قد
يجيز احتلال القدس قد يطبع اوراق النقديه
يشتري بها ثروات الشعوب بعد اعلان كوريا
الشماليه فشل محاوله اطلاق اول قمر
استطلاع عسكري تابع لها تتحدث كيم يو جونغ
وهي شقيقه الزعيم الكوري كيم جونغ اون عن
محاوله اخرى لوضع قمر التجسس العسكري في
المدار جعل كيم جونغ اون من تطوير اقمار
صناعيه كهذه اولويه عسكريه وهو برنامج
تقول الولايات المتحده انه يستخدم
تكنولوجيا الصواريخ الباليسيه الممنوعه
دوريا القوه النوويه الكوريه والفطره
الاوغنديه السويه اقلقت واشنطن هذا
الاسبوع فقد عاقب البيت الابيض اوغندا
السمراء بسبب تجريمها الشذوذ الجنسي والغي
التاشيره كانت قد منحتها لرئيسه البرلمان
الاوغندي اوغندا تتلقى مساعدات ماليه ملحه
من الغرب لكن الرزق على الله يقول
البرلماني الاوغندي المسلم عثمان بصل
الرواه الذي دعا حكومته الى طلب العون من
دول عربيه خليجيه
ثقافته على شعوب ترفضها هو السقوط الذي
ينبغي ان ينتقد وليس سقوط المتكرر للرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن على الارض
اهلنا سقطوا كبارا ومرارا وقد احترمنا
سقوطهم بصمت والم لكن من اراد ان يسخر من
اصرار جو بايدن على الترشح مجددا
للانتخابات المقبله فله ذلك في المجتمعات
الديمقراطيه
كثيره
باعتراف نادر وجريء من مؤتمر الاساقفه
الكاثولي جرائم الاغتصاب والتحرش من رجال
الكنائس الكاثوليكيه باسبانيا تطفو على
سطح التحقيقات المؤتمر كشف عن مئات جرائم
الاعتداء الجنسي على قاصرين وسوء المعامله
الكنسيه جل المعتدين من الذكور ونصفهم
رجال دين توفي ثلثاهم بتقدم العمر
فالاعتداءات بدات منذ 80 عاما وقد ابقى
المؤتمر عدد الضحايا مفتوحا مع تسجيل
حالات جديده
ووصف تقرير الاساقفه الاسبان بانه الاحدث
والاكثر جراه في سلسله فضائح الاعتداءات
الجنسيه المماثله داخل كنائس امريكا
وبريطانيا وفرنسا وبوليفيا وايرلندا
والمانيا
بعد اليوم لا تستخدم مصطلح الامه
الاسلاميه لان فريده الشوباسي مفطيه
معجونه البلاط كما توصف يعني مش البلاط
المعجونه يلي جمعت البلاطات على بعض لا
تسمحوا باطلاق وصف الامه على شعوب
المسلمين الذي اقره الله تعالى في اكثر من
ايه قرانيه كريمه يحفظها الصغير والكبير
الايه 92 من سوره الانبياء ان هذه امتكم
امه واحده وانا ربكم فاعبدون صدق الله
العظيم وغيرها كثير فهي الامه الوسط وهي
خير امه وستبقى كذلك رغم مرورها بمرحله
انحطاط فريده ما فيش حاجه اسمها الامه
الاسلام ما فيش حاجه اسمها الامه
الاسلاميه ما فيش حاجه اسمها امه دين وانا
رايي ان ده بقى ضمن مخطط التفتيت اللي كان
يدبر للوطن المصري والوطن العربي كله
واحنا شفنا اللي حوالينا ايه اللي حصل
لولا المعجزه الالهيه بتاعه 30 يونيو
وربنا كمل هديته الحمد لله بعد الفتاح
السيسي الرئيس عبده الفتاح السيسي يستخدم
دائما في بياناته وخطاباته مصطلح الامه
الاسلاميه ومصر هي احدى كبريات دول هذه
الامه الاسلاميه
ودعائمها رئيس السيسي عبر صفحته الرسميه
بمواقع التواصل الاجتماعي الامه الاسلاميه
والشعب المصري بمناسبه حلول عيد الفطر
المبارك وفقنا الله جميعا في خدمه قضايا
الامه الاسلاميه والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته المطبعه الكويتيه مع دوله
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي فجر السعيد طردت امس
من مطار بيروت ومنعت من دخول لبنان بسبب
وجود تاشيره اسرائيليه على جواز سفرها
الكويتي فجر السعيد التي اشتهرت برفع
الاحذيه على الهواء اراد التطوير نفسها
لكنها اساءت للقدس وانتحلت مقام العلماء
فافتت جهلا او فجورا بان معراج النبي الى
السماء لم يكن اولى القبلتين بل بناه ثاني
الخلفاء فهل تتكرم فجر بالبقاء في دائره
حلقات الاحذيه بعيدا عن مقدسات المسلمين
يسال متابعون كويتيون
مثل الاعلاميه الكويتيه فجر السعيد
المتابعين بتصرف اعتبره البعض غير لائق
ابدا لامراه في مكانتها وعمرها حيث قامت
برفع حذائها على الهواء مباشره
والتلويح بها والتوجه للفنانه السوريه
اصاله نصري قائله انها ستضربها بالحذاء
حين رؤيتها انا ودي استعمله
والله وان شاء الله بستعملها قريبا في
وحده ببالي
يعني ان شاء الله
اذا فجر السعيد تنكر الحقائق الثابته حول
المسجد الاقصى المبارك
ه
المسجد الاقصى اللي بناء عمر بن الخطاب
عمر بن الخطاب لم يكن خليفه للمسلمين الا
بعد وفاه الرسول في شلون اولى القبلتين
يصلي على اي قبله يقول المثل الشعبي نبع
القريه لا يروي عطش اهلها فجر في الكويت
والداعيه الشيخ عثمان الخميس ايضا في
الكويت ويعلم ويعلموا تاريخ الاقصى
والمسجد الاقصى بناه يعقوب
حفيد ابراهيم
والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ما سئل عن اول
بيت وضع للناس قال المسجد الحرام ومعلوم
المسجد الحرام انه ابراهيم قال ثم ماذا
قال المسجد الاقصى قال كم بينهما قال
اربعون سنه عقيله الرئيس الامريكي جيل
بايدن احترمت ثقافه المسلمين اثناء
زيارتها للجامع الازهر في القاهره
فحافظت على الحشمه ووضعت غطاء للراس لدى
دخولها المسجد ولقاء المشايخ
[موسيقى]
في المتفرقات مباريات الجمال ايضا تحتاج
الى ثقافه تقبل الخساره في البرازيل حطم
شاب تاج ملكه جمال البلاد لحظه تتويجها
لانها تفوقت على زوجته التي لا يرى اجمل
منها في البرازيل سترونها المواقف الغريبه
في حفلات تتويج ملكات الجمال لا تتوقف
اخرها تحطيم زوج غاضب التاج الملكي بحفل
تتويج ملكات الجمال في البرازيل لعدم
اختيار زوجته للفوز باللقب الزوج خطف
التاج عند تتويج الملكه ورماه ارضا ثم سحب
زوجته نتالي بيكر بعيدا عن المسرح نجم
هوليود الباتشينو باعوامه الثلاثه
ينتظر مولودا من صديقته الشابه العشرينيه
والمقيمه معه في الولايات المتحده نور
الفلاح
لم يصدق الامر بدايه فطالب صديقته بفحص
حمض نووي للحمل استجابت وكانت النتيجه
ايجابيه الطفل ابنه وسينضم الى قائمه
ابنائه من صديقاته بدون زواج علما ان
كثيرا من الاثرياء في الغرب يتجنبون
الزواج نظرا لقانون الاحوال الشخصيه في
الغرب الذي يمنح الزوجه المطلقه نصف ثروه
الزوج وقد اضطر الملياردير جيف بيزوس قبل
اربع سنوات الى تحويل ثروه من ثمانيه
وثلاثين مليار دولار لحساب طليقته قبل ان
تتزوج لاحقا مدرسه اطفالها بعمر ثلاثه
وثمانين عاما الباتشينو ينتظر طفله الرابع
من صديقته الكويتيه صاحبه 29 عاما لم
يعتقد الباتشينو انه قادر على الانجاب
بهذا العمر لذا بعد ان ثبت حمل صديقته
المنتجه الكويتيه نور الفلاح اجبرها على
اجراء اختبار حمض نووي لاثبات هويه الطفل
واظهر الاختبار انه هو الاب الحقيقي ونور
هي منتجه امريكيه كويتيه الاصل تخرجت من
جامعه جنوب كاليفورنيا ودرست الفنون
السينمائيه اما الباتشينو فلديه ثلاثه
اطفال من علاقات سابقه
[موسيقى]
مشهد للتاريخ طرزه الاردنيون بالامس فرحا
بزفاف اميرهم الحسين ببهجه عفويه غمرت
ارجاء المملكه تزامنا مع مراسم الزفاف
الرسميه
نفرح بالحسين شعار رفعه الاردنيون في كل
مكان ليظل محفورا في ذاكره من شهد
احتفائهم بزفاف ملكي امتد على مساحه الوطن
نفهم احتفال الاردنيين بعرس ولي عهدهم
الامير الحسين فهو حدث لا يتكرر غالبا لكن
من يستطيع ان يفهم احتفالا غريبا جرت
مراسيمه في الباديه الاردنيه
احتفاءا بتوثيق حساب سناب شات حضرته فود
من داخل الاردن وخارجه واستاهله المحتفى
بحسابه بشكر والده على حسن التربيه
والرعايه من الولاده وصولا الى يوم توثيق
الحساب السع فتوثيق الحسابات الالكترونيه
امر يتكرر مره واحده كل ثانيه ويحيي كل من
تعنى وكل من جانا من الاردن ولا من خارج
الاردن يلا انت حيهم
اللهم لك الحمد والله يبيض وجه كل من جانا
وكل من شاركنا فرحتنا والله العلي العظيم
ورساله اول رساله اوجهها بعد التوثيق لها
الرجل هذا والدي اشكرك على حسن التربيه
لنا وشكرك على كل شيء طيب وكل حياتك
وقفاتك واتعبك علشاننا كل الشكر والله يا
ابوي
[موسيقى]
استمر وطور سنابك
اخيرا صحفي رياضي مصري يوجه سؤالا لمدرب
النادي الاهلي مرسال كولر الذي لا يتكلم
اللغه العربيه بتاتا سفر عربي ازاي سالوا
صاحبنا وفي اي لغه بل باي لغه شاهدوا
الفيديو قبل ان يحذف فهو يهدد مستقبل
الذكاء الصناعي
[موسيقى]
ان ايجيبت اي واحد مصري كلنا كمصريين كلنا
العرب كنا متوقعين نظرا للاداء الجيد
للنادي الاهلي خلال العشر اشهر والسنه
والس نه اللي فاتت
القمه في افريقيا
ما هو رايك او استعداداتك لنتغلب عن هذا
الهدف الذي دخلنا في اخر العشر دقايق وكنا
يستحق ان لا يدخل فينا
[موسيقى]
ختاما يحدث ان يخرج من حين لاخر من يدق
الجدر الكبيره باصابع صغيره بايقاع لا
يفسر في المقلب الاخر كيف فعل ومن هذا كيف
رحل ولماذا له اشباه يقراون كتابه هل
فرحوا امنعوا شباب اسئله يحترف الاجابه
عليها عشرات الوف الاحياء في القبور
وملايين المنتظرين فوق فهل يفيق من عصي
عليه الفهم الى معادله لا حل لها الا
بالرحيل الى اللقاء
سلم على كل عمرك
عن الحريه
لكن بلدك مش نا
سي وشك متزوق بتضيع
مكسب
[موسيقى]
وحياهك في وراك اخواتك
ارتاح انت وحقك
[موسيقى]